we live in this mirror hologram
essentially
but in this mirror hologram it's like
the reflection is also real it's not
false it's not just a reflection so
you're seeing a perfect replica on the
external as you've got on the internal
so that means that like you know you may
reject an aspect of self but so do they
that same one or just something
different it depends on the circumstance
yeah
like i'll get i'll get more clear so
let's say that you yourself have an
issue with your anger right
you'll be a match to somebody else who
also has an issue with anger
and so you're going to get it both from
your internal and from the external
while your internal part is like this is
not acceptable we should be able to
regulate ourselves right now you'll get
a partner who's like i'm not okay with
your anger this is really immature you
know or whatever it is so
yeah because that's familiar is that
like the like attract like kind of
situation or is it just because we
find something similar in someone else
that resonates with us no it's because
we live in a universe that's based off
of the law of miriam which is what many
people call the law of attraction this
was designed as a 360 degree mirror
hologram for the sake of the perception
of expansion
so it like you cannot escape the fact
that you will see on the external
whatever is on the internal
that's an it's like a law of our time
space reality otherwise nobody would
come down to this earth so why don't
people love themselves
because of the process of socialization
so to understand that process we have to
go back to the childhood experience
where when we're in an environment like
this as a social species there's like a
code of conduct for how we have to
live so as to coexist as a group
and there are more exalted forms of this
but right now we're living in a real
shadow form of this and have been
forever where
in childhood a child has to be raised up
into this
you know position to understand what is
acceptable and what is unacceptable
what will get them rejected and what
will get them accepted
and we all go through this process of
socialization if we're part of human
society but it is that process that
teaches us what aspects of ourselves
like i said are going to get us pushed
away
and in a social group
which i think it's really important that
people accept that they're a social
species you know it's i as i go around
the planet it's been very difficult to
try to get people to under understand
what they need and what's going wrong
because they can't even see themselves
clearly you know when you're stepping in
from an outside perspective if you take
humans as a species it's a group species
it's like a herd species
and that means that the well-being of
the individual human is inseparable from
the group
this presents an issue with
socialization because our survival as
humans is so linked to our connection to
other people
that we actually will pray play like
this internal triangulation game
so as to stay connected with the people
upon whom our life depends
and so it's like what i like to do is
take people back in time to think about
themselves as a tiny infant if i was to
take a tiny infant and if i scoop to go
put them outside they're dying
we are so
completely dependent for so long and
even when we are able to meet our needs
technically
our well-being is still dependent upon
the connection with the group
so it's important for people to first
get i am a group species
and therefore my well-being is not
independent of my connection to other
people so in childhood when when you've
got that fundamental aspect of yourself
and that we could consider more primal
element of the
nervous system hooked into the group
when you've got mom or dad or any member
of society especially an adult who's
telling you
it doesn't need to be verbal like this
can be you know through their words
their actions through a look you know if
they're doing anything in response to us
we learn very quickly good bad right
wrong
threat to me not and so when i i'm
talking about this internal
triangulation dynamic let's talk about
triangulation triangulation is
essentially where i try to establish
closeness to the exclusion of
so we see this in our social groups like
you know as girls like we've you know
how it is to kind of be like oh my gosh
you know
michelle she was like totally unfair to
you just then so it's it's a way to sort
of push somebody away so as to develop
rapport and we have this exact same
relationship dynamic going on but in the
internal world and this is where
self-hate begins
when we perceive that an aspect of
ourselves is
not going to be accepted by the group
that we're around we push that aspect of
ourselves away so as to gain closeness
with those people in our lives
so it's an internal triangulation game
against certain aspects of self and to
the degree that we experience an aspect
of ourselves causing pain for us
we will experience the same degree of
hatred towards that part because
underneath all hatred is pain and then
it's a lifelong process of pushing that
aspect away trying to suppress it trying
to deny it trying to cut it off you know
and and this is really where we can't
stay in this integrated state we can't
take that part of us as a part of us
ourselves
and that is where you know to take that
definition of love beyond you know the
other
that's where our self-love falls apart
ideally thinking that if you loved all
aspects of yourself then that would sort
of be the cure to loving others and
feeling the love of others as well i
don't like to differentiate between the
two at a certain level the point at
which to make something about the self
versus the others is the point at which
you're looking to get somebody into a
state of empowerment
there's something inherently
disempowering about depending on the
external to make a change for yourself
to feel good so that's the point of
which we start to look at at concepts
like loving myself makes it so the
external can love me but if we go to a
higher dimensional level you see that
there's actually no difference between
the external and the internal so loving
other is loving the self there is
nothing but self-love
so i think it's important to
sometimes to like take the pressure off
having to love the self so as to get
love from the external even though we
recognize this mirror construct there
ultimately is no difference
it's just it would benefit us
to not be walking around in the state of
disintegration
to not be walking around in a state of
fragmentation
where we've got this internal war going
on
we're all looking for internal peace and
you also hear that especially in the
self development fields and
in the spiritual field you just hear
this like catchphrase in inner peace and
peace like all over the place and
it's like what the hell is that
that's a state where you don't have an
aspect of self against another aspect
that's a state where there's a
recognition of value in all aspects and
the integration occurs so that you can
draw from the best aspects of all of
these parts of self
and you've got a harmonious
system going on rather than
war within the system
so is the concept of trying to heal the
self heal the trauma heal the wounds
you know
cultivate your relationship with your
inner child all those kinds of things is
that
an old sort of
methodology of
of
evolving and should it really just be
shifting your consciousness to a level
that is
just accept understanding that
everything is a part of us i don't see
them as exclusive from one another
i feel like that is the most profoundly
healing step that you can take
it's just when you start to look at
the process of self-development of the
process of healing through that lens of
integration
you don't fall into as many pitfalls as
when you're focusing on i need to fix
myself or heal myself or you know do
whatever because even the process of
self-healing and the process of shadow
work can become so incredibly abusive
it can become like i need to fix this
part of mine because the background
noises because it's not okay you know
yeah when it's like it just becomes this
you're almost on the treadmill that
never ends because
you can't
hate yourself
into needing to change
and love yourself at the same time
yeah that makes sense
well this seems like a it seems like um
i'm not gonna it sounds it feels like a
set up to fail kind of existence the
human experience really feels really
tricky and it feels like you know
there's a lot of confusion suffering and
not being able to see the self and not
being able to
understand really what's going on
there's i mean the human experience is a
whole bunch of it's your fault not mine
and and
and it feels like that's just is that
the way it's designed to be
to help us grow and evolve no
what happened then where did we go wrong
resistance
human beings are more capable of going
into a state of resistance than almost
any other species and part of that is
because you could consider mankind to be
a manifestation of the mind of god let's
like say those words you know we're
looking at source which we could define
as the collective consciousness of all
things in existence
each species is essentially a
manifestation of an aspect of
what we would call source
so mind is actually what human beings
have manifested as a result of
and that makes things very tricky
because while you have all of these
amazing capacities that come along with
that you also have these incredible
shadows that come along with that
like for example you know you can see
the beauty of
being a species that has the capacity to
help source define itself
a species that has come down
with this intention of helping source
become aware you know the problem with
that though is to become aware of the
self is to have an ego so you see the
human is in a state of ego more so than
almost any other species because of this
very same trait and i i think it's very
important to realize that
everything comes with contrast so every
time we have like this incredible you
know ability
to the flip side of that is some kind of
a shadow that can get us into a lot of
trouble and what we're seeing with
humanity is
this massive trouble
with uh you know the shadow aspect of
the manifestation of what they're what
makes them so brilliant ultimately so
where does the shadow come from
unawareness that's all the shadow is
it's not even like it comes from
anywhere it's just like what is not
exposed to to the consciousness
and why is it that we is this part of
fragmentation is that basically and when
is fragmentation a part of the shadow
like does the shadow emerge when we
fragment yes in a human yes
it's we whatever so this is how to how
to put this like let's say that you're
growing up in your childhood and
anger is not okay
in your in the upbringing that you have
so you will go and do your best to
suppress deny disown
push away from your consciousness that
aspect of yourself a part of what goes
along with that is to to make it become
shadow meaning it's not what we are
conscious of anymore
and the mind essentially does that
because it's an efficiency machine
and it's trying to
it's trying to do the best that it can
with the directives that it's given so
it's like this gets us in trouble right
but the problem is like within each one
of these these shadows should we call it
is something really really
valuable we call this shadow gold so
like within your anger is the capacity
to know where your limits are
with no anger there is no limit
sure
so
so let's say you buried your limits at
the same time as you've buried your
anger and so all of a sudden you're
unaware of all your limits as well
that's going to be great in
relationships and great you know walking
around your day-to-day life and whatever
it is so yeah that process of
fragmentation that occurs as a result of
splitting off from and then suppressing
denying disowning the aspect of self
makes it go into this place within a
person where they are no longer aware of
it
[Music]